what's with the notebooks calls today
around wait let me guess not all of them
I don't believe in love what is the
craziest most romantic thing you've ever
done for love either of you guys I don't
know if there's anything crazy but one
thing that I do currently I've always
written letters I write letters at my
latest Academy there's just something
about opening right the letter and
reading it I put like Friday
I hope listen this time you know there's
just something very just simple requires
a little bit more work I think maybe
when you just order flowers for somebody
you know and just but there's something
about writing a letter to find a stamp
we're gonna know yeah I do the stamp
like they don't sell them a UPS so
nobody you so no magic no fate no meant
to be what if I told you I could get you
to fall in love with me just give me a
day an hour
what is one line that you remember from
one of the letters that you've written
roses are red violets are blue look at
this guy because I did use make that up
no I don't know it's real it's real it's
in a letter I was like a third grade
letter I want to talk a little bit about
your chemistry in the movie unbelievable
oh this isn't gonna make me change my
mind mr. plaid time did you just call me
Pat I'm glad time my family is from
Korea in that Thailand that is not what
I said so you can stop waiting for
apology oh I'm waiting for something but
not for an apology now did that come
naturally for you guys or did you have
to work on it a little bit I don't feel
like it came naturally because we're
such our characters mm-hmm and we were
able to actually go on the journey that
our characters were going on
but I think I could love what about
those steamy make-out sessions did you
guys have any like makeout mishaps or
what were the secret to getting those so
good routine
I think is just you know a matter of the
director and our cinematographer ha no
because we were pretty invested in our
characters and when it came to being on
said it wasn't nice turning it on when
it was action to cut we were truly
embodied the characters and showed up to
work and just you know let the you know
we did our what we did what our job was
and then be a lot of tuna eat a lot of
tuna like yeah I would give me breakfast
before every make out saying I'm gonna
get the spray mystery so bad mouth shhh
I mean literally the chemistry was
unbelievable you guys I mean even like I
remember in particular like the
hand-holding scene in the movie theater
like I didn't know a hand-holding scene
could be done so well oh man it's really
funny because that was one scene where
is possibly most like one of the most
unromantic things to like shoot if you
were in that environment right in the
planetarium at night which was
incredible but we were running out of
time
and so it was like everyone was moving
around packing up and we're doing this
scene but it was really funny because
like we're in our own little world and
there are people rushing out oh I think
I was Wheatley films like usually we
were filming every day you know cuz the
movie obviously takes pain in the day
right yeah this is the first time when
everything you could see everyone
getting tired
we're tickling each other's hands that
was kind of real
when your key ingredients to fall in
love my ingredients are friendship
chemistry The X Factor what's the X
Factor don't worry we've got it I have
to give you guys a huge congratulations
I mean just being the leading roles for
this movie what does it mean to you it's
great to the audience's that we've been
seeing at these screenings they've been
so diverse you know and to have a love
story there's so many different love
stories and then we can we can all agree
that we can connect to a story of love
but you know sometimes the picture that
covers that love story and to have a
black Iranian and a korean-american on
the cover of this love story with so
many timely themes right now is such
it's so amazing it's so truthful and
what are you so afraid of listen I
wasn't born here why my family is
leaving tomorrow we mentioned the timely
things and obviously this movie speaks
to a cultural and political moment
that's happening right now immigration
and deportation was that one of the
deciding factors for you guys to join
this project to be able to tell that
story most definitely I feel like that's
what also makes us extremely elevated
because I know how many of our peers
have to hold all of these truths at once
of their own cultural identity own
immigration status any other layering
identity on top of that plus just being
a human I you know anyone in this day
and age has been inundated with stories
of family separation of all of these
things and so to be able to tell a story
that really is steeped in what we're
going through right now but it also has
this universal kind of theme and when we
understand the idea and the around
belonging and the politics of belonging
have never went away like they they've
been ever-present and so to have a movie
that really revels in what it means to
belong and what it means to care about
other people is all really special who
don't have forever
[Music]
all we have is a single day
[Music]